hello everyone and welcome to some
extremely joyous news from the chess
world uh we have a new youngest grand
master
it is a united states uh international
master abhimanyu mishra now a grand
master
and uh it was quite the journey he
finally
reached his third grand master norm and
for those of you who are new to chess to
achieve the title of grandmaster you
need three grand master norms which
means you need to
finish uh three tournaments uh with uh
with an elo rating performance
over over 2600 which is not a small feat
and you need to have an actual rating in
classical chess over 2500 so those are
the
uh requirements of to becoming a
grandmaster
and here going into this tournament
mishra already had two norms
and he had a rating of 2500 so he just
needs to do well in this tournament
and by just i mean he has to fare well
against many strong grandmasters
uh to achieve the third final norm and
achieve his title of grand master and
here he faces
um uh 67th indian grandmaster he got his
grandmaster title in january this year
uh leon luke mendonka and his uh well as
you'll see in this game a very fierce
opponent
so without further ado let's check it
out and we're gonna discuss a little bit
more after we check out the game
uh and also uh this is the uh it was
played in the last round of the
ezra kepso grand master mix in budapest
where uh he
got all of his norms uh and uh also
he was doing extremely well in the
tournament he was on five out of six and
then he lost
the slovak grand master milan parker
then he bounced back in round eight with
a win
and now this is round nine the final
round and it's uh it's quite the game
so without further ado let's check it
out mendonka with the white pieces opens
with
d4 and uh the game as you'll see is very
nice
so knight to f6 we have c4 g6
knight the c3 end uh mishra goes for d5
he goes for the groomfield defense
uh and now common here is just captures
or knight f3 batman donkey goes for
bishop to f4
also they're very popular uh we have
bishop to g7 and
now e3 we have castles by abi manu and
now rook the c1 going for the capablanca
variation against this line of the
groomfield
we have c5 striking in the center and
now
d captures on c5 so it's a temporary
font sacrifice
uh so you you want to grab some rapid
development
bishop to e6 we have knight to f3 white
also needs to continue developing pieces
he has to get his king to safety
black king is already very safe on that
g8 square
knights the c6 and the bishop to eat you
know so white now also raided the castle
with uh
and here comes queen to a5 so black can
always pick up the pawn it's not really
an issue but
black is uh enjoying his position very
much
uh and here we have knight to g5 just
going after that bishop on e6 so what
did abhimanyo prepare for this game
uh well the position has been reached
before known moves are okay today rook
f2 d8
uh knights the e4 also a known move but
here we have knight back to d8 and it is
now
already as of move 10 did we have a
completely new game
so defending this bishop and saying if
you go for it for example knight
captures captures and captures
i'm just going to capture on f4 mess up
your pawn structure here
and then uh well yeah the position is
just very nice for black yes you do have
two pawns but after
some like rook to d8 uh you you will
never be able to keep them i'm just
going to play queen captures on c5 and
that's it for example
castles queen captures on c5 and then
white is left with the isolated d-pawn
which you can of course play if you
enjoy isolated pawns
uh some do some don't uh but uh he
decides against it uh as uh well
he he knows that this is unexplored
territory so he just retreats bishop to
g3
and now d captures on c4 this is now a
nicely protected pawn
we have knight captures on e6
eliminating the defender of the pawn
at knight captures and now queen to a4
offering a queen trade
but uh abi of course doesn't want to
trade he goes queen captures in c5
and now bishop captures on c4
and here we have queen to b6 saying okay
our king is still in the center of the
board i'm just going to put some
pressure here on the b
pawn and i want to clear the c file for
my rooks so what do you play here so
here
queen to b3 offering a queen trade uh
and
now black accepts we have queen captures
on b3
bishop captures and now knight to c5
looking to
ruin white's pawn structure with knight
captures bishop here and this is a very
strong bishop white still has
the bishop pair so you do want to
eliminate one of them so now
uh those who enjoy playing with the
bishop pair probably will go bishop back
to c2 and tuck the bishop in for later
uh but here eminka says nope i'm just
gonna play kingy to bring my rook into
the game and you're welcome to capture
here i don't see any any problems
so knight captures on b3 a captures and
now the rooks come into the game rook
f2d8
rook h2d1 and now knight the e8 opening
up this um
uh dark square bishop's diagonal uh but
also just shifting the knight uh
into into the game uh via via maybe d6
or c7 later on
so here we have a trade of rooks we have
rook captures rook captures and now he
offers a
a trade of the other pair of rooks as
well he could keep the rooks on the
board go rook to a1 or just
you know start advancing pawns but he
decides to take the rooks of the board
and he wants to play this minor piece
end game so here we have rook captures
on d1
and the king captures on d1 and now
comes knight to f6
so now the knight comes back into the
game
we have king to c2 and now knight to d7
and now black is looking into playing
something like f5 e5 he does have some
nice control of the e5 squares
and then start bringing his king into
the game and you do have an
advantage on the queen side as black has
doubled b pawn
so it it's definitely a weakness where
you can take advantage of this
it all depends on what white plays so
here b4
uh taking away the b5 the c5 square from
blacks knight also you know making just
making room for the king so he can enter
the game
uh we have f5 and now knight to b5
attacking the a7 pawn we have a6 and now
knight to c7 so what do you play here
black starts bringing the king into the
game king f7
now comes b5 but uh by white obviously
uh trying to trade off a pair of pawns
we have a5 black wants to keep as many
pawns on the board as
black has double pawns uh white has
double pawns black doesn't so of course
the black doesn't want to
get rid of white's only weakness for
free so of course he advances the pawn
uh we have knight to d5 uh and now
knight to c5 uh we have bishop to c7 now
going after the a5 pawn
and a4 now defending uh so how do you
prevent uh how do you prevent the white
king from entering the
the game uh well so far you're doing a
fine job at the pawn guards this square
the bishop covers this square and
the knight covers this square so the
king is for the moment locked out of the
game
but with f3 white uh isn't really
worried about that
and king e6 uh dislodging the knight
from such a powerful square
knight to c3 and now he asks what do you
what are you going to do here i i can't
go forward with my king but i'm not even
trying to it's you who
need a win to become the youngest grand
master ever so here uh
bimanu makes a very interesting choice
uh and he plays
bishop captures on c3 and it seems odd
uh giving up uh a long range piece like
that when we have played on both sides
of the board
the entire uh board is still full full
of pawns
uh but the thing is after king captures
on c3 notice that uh his pawns are all
on light squares okay except this one
but that's easily uh fixable
uh and uh he ha uh the opponent has a
dark square bishop so
maybe just maybe the knight is a little
bit better here than the bishop but
we'll see what happens
king to d5 you have to bring your king
as close as possible
uh to the action and now bishop to d8
forcing black to
get rid of this uh pawn from a dark
square
so while you could play e6 he decides to
advance it all the way to e5
and then he's going to push it to e4 to
lock his spawns on light squares this
way
so bishop to e7 uh and not knight to b3
both of them were already as a very low
on time here so
uh calculating whether you can allow the
trade here and uh
maybe just go into a king and pawn end
game uh there's no need to do this uh
chances are higher of you know just uh
prolonging the game as long as needed to
achieve a win
uh with pieces on the board and here uh
we have
h3 here a white could have gone with
king to b4 but like i said both of them
were low on time
it's hard to calculate everything and
the point is here
your a for pawn is now under attack and
black has to resort to this knight d2
king captures knight c4 now attacking
these two pawns and the ones black white
defends one of them let's say bishop g5
now you pick up this pawn with
check king a5 and now knight to c4 locks
out
the king uh from from entering deeper
into the position
you have to go back and on ib6 and the
game continues but it's
uh not much for black white is actually
very happy with this so it might not be
a bad idea white played h3 instead
and now black maybe gets a a pretty
valuable tempo so here we have e4
uh f captures an e4 and now not king
captures which
seems like a good idea but f captures
instead
and why why did he capture with the pawn
instead of with the king well
this is his plan king the b4 attacking
the pawn
and now knight the d2 so again what do
you play here
here we have bishop to f6 uh now after
uh the the knight attacks both of these
pawns you can always shift the bishop
here to
to help out with with the defense uh and
now
again you could go for knight to c4 but
then we played this and then for example
knight to d2 king captures on a4 we're
going to play king to c4
and whether white can survive this this
uh king march going
after these pawns it's it's hard to say
and very hard to calculate under
uh well being low on time so instead
after bishop to f6 we have
h5 and now comes king captures on a4
uh king to c4 now uh uh well
winning a lot a lot of important squares
here we have king the a5 going for this
to pick off the uh b7 pawn and not
knight to b3 check king to b6 and now
knight to c5 defending this pawn
so what do you play here well for the
moment you can't really move your king
as the knight
would be hanging so here just bishop to
d4 defending all of the pawns attacking
the knight
and black is not doing great here he's
down a pawn and
uh it seems like he maybe maybe got
into a little bit of trouble but uh
there's
there's
a saying whenever there's a knight on
the board there's a chance
knight to be three so what do you play
here if you go for king captures on b7
then we play knight captures on b4
uh and of course if pawn captures then
this pawn advances but
this is even playable but you have to
play b6
and uh i mean who can calculate these
things under
a severe time pressure for example
knight to e6 you're gonna play king to
c6 to get your pawn up the board but now
uh we
we're gonna play uh h4 and
now after king to d6 going after the
knight because
if you advance the pawn here for example
you push b7 we can just play knight to
d8 to check and give the piece back and
win the pawn
so we're going to play king for example
to d6 but now comes knight to c5 again
we guard the b7 square
and now we're going to play b3 with
check trying to get the king away from
the defense of the knight or the knight
from the defense of the b7 square
and now after king to b4 uh we're gonna
play king to d5 king to b5 now
and then b7 but now knight captures king
captures on e4 and
this all resolves in a draw so here
after knight to b3
we have bishop to f6 by white and now
comes king to b4
but now only now king captures on b7 and
this was a bit rushed you don't have to
go for it right away you should keep the
tension play something like g4 maybe
but here he captured the pawn right away
and now black captures on b5 we have
king to c7
king to c4 king to d6 and now king to d3
so now it's again a race
we have bishop to g5 defending the pawn
and now knight to d2 and here
uh the thing is you have to play b4 or
something like king to e6 and you're
doing fine
but white played king to e5 and he
allowed black such a
sneaky maneuver that you know it's
almost as if kaiser smiled at
the young uh you know just
to to achieve this uh prestigious title
at such a young age
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best move for
black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the nasty
fork
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to f3
with check and now what do you play here
well you most certainly don't capture
the knight you have to play king to f4
and then you are again allowed to draw
this game for example knight captures
and g5 king captures king captures on e3
and now b4 is enough to draw the game uh
king f2 we're going to play b5 e3
b6 e2 b7 and now both players get a
queen into the game
and that's it there there's no winning
this it's completely equal uh queen
queen opponent game
so instead after knight to f3 check he
didn't move the king he captured the
knight he accepted the challenge but
this will lead to his demise uh as
after he captures on f3 we now have
bishop to h4 you have to guard this
square if you don't then black's just
gonna promote to a queen
and now g5 white cannot accept this pawn
because then we just
get a queen so instead we have bishop to
f2 but now comes king to
e2 further harassing the bishop and now
there's no escaping because if you go
here we follow and if you go here we
follow and that's it
there that that's just game you're going
to promote this pawn
again to a queen and win the game so
here white started pushing the pawn
but now it's simply too slow because
there's a very very neat
trick in the end uh king capture sun f2
was played b5
we have king capture sun e3 b6 we have
f2
uh b7 and now f1 queen and it was in
this position anmo 55
that leon luke mendonka resigned to the
game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is if white brings a queen into the game
we have this
very very nasty queen to f4 check and
now you have to move the king we pick up
the queen and now of course it's
completely winning for black
so really really incredible a lot of
twists to this game but like i said it's
almost as if kaiser smiled at
a young abhimanyu mishra so he will
achieve this
great great achievement and break
karakin's record
uh by over two months uh as i've uh as
i've learned
uh so yeah uh he became a grand master
now at the age of 12 years
four months and 25 days uh more than two
months uh prior to sergey karakin who's
been
holding the title for uh i i think 18 or
19 years
so really really incredible achievement
uh congratulations to young abi
and uh well as you see there they are
getting younger and younger very soon we
will be having an 11 year old
grandmaster then a 10 year old
grandmaster and then i mean
uh it is just incredible how how
fast they are they are progressing and
how or how how quickly you know
they are achieving this incredible
incredible norm
uh so yeah what's your take on that i
mean it seems simply incredible
a huge congratulations to young abby
and uh you know wish you all all the
best in your in your future endeavors
uh so yeah uh that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh feel free to
join in the congratulations uh tayan
gabi
uh i would like to thank nigel holloway
aleandra motorson happy birthday ccp er
constantino buchi and vlad larry for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon i continue in
the coverage of the other tournament
that we're covering
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day